In podcasts 50 for the armed forces officer.
Remember that book?
The Armed Forces officer?
Yeah.
One of my feet.
1950 edition.
Yeah.
Can you expound on the difference between these two?
These two seemingly contradictory quotes from the manual?
A firm hold at the beginning pays 10 fold dividend of the timid approach
followed by a show of firmness later on from general Malone story of a World War
One compared with
and General Malone's.
If you remember the story was there's like mad messed up unit and he went in
there was like,
all right,
get squared away because these boards in place get out of the mud.
What you need to get your uniforms together.
Just tighten them up out of the gate.
Like firmness,
firmness really out of the gate.
Yeah.
And then compare it to,
to um,
okay.
Here's the quote.
It's a mistake for an officer on taking a new post to order sweeping changes
affecting the other men in the belief that this will give him a reputation for
action and firmness.
The studying of situations is the overture of the studying of it and that's from
General Lemay
in general or May.
If you remember that one,
he said,
hey,
none of you guys would be in these positions unless you were doing things right.
So I assume that you're doing a good job and we're going to continue what you're
doing.
That's what he said when he took over.
So what's going on here is you've got two completely different situations and
the two situations are,
one is a guy taking over for a situation,
unknown bad situation.
The troops are lacking discipline,
they're not executing the mission.
And if you remember from that story,
they weren't even doing basic military bearing.
They didn't,
they weren't saluting the officers.
They just hadn't thrown everything out the window.
That's a situation you've got to come and you've got to get from out of the
gate.
That's what you gotta do.
Now they got to know that.
They got to know that things are gonna Change.
They got to know it's real.
They got to know there's a new plan and they've got to know what that new plan
is.
And then they got to know that there's new standards and they got to know what
the new standards are.
Boom,
and it's the same thing.
You know,
Hackworth.
He did that.
He came in with some,
you know,
if you remember when he took over the,
the hardcore battalion,
what became the hardcore battalion,
the first thing he did was like all those radios and guitars and all this crap
that you have sitting around base.
Put it all in the middle of the base tomorrow and we're getting rid of it all.
That was a big change.
Now Hackworth.
Then he,
then he started implementing two changes a day.
If you remember,
Hey,
got to get everyone,
carry your weapon at all times.
That's the neck change.
Okay,
get your helmet.
now we've got to get helmet covers on it.
He just made one,
one or two small changes a day after he made some big sweeping changes out of
the gate because it was a jacked up battalion and now,
now the differences,
if you're going into a situation where everything's going fine or okay or at a
bare minimum,
it's like normal.
Well then you don't need to step in there and show that you're the man by making
these sweeping changes.
You don't need to do that.
It comes across,
it comes across like the people that you just took charge of.
I have no idea what they're doing and get you.
You don't respect what they,
what they,
what their methodology.
You don't respect their,
their performance because you're coming in and saying,
oh echo,
by the way,
the way you report the cord,
the podcast,
you need to get rid of those microphones.
You need to edit it tighter,
your basis to,
you know,
what would you be thinking if I came in and said that?
Well,
you know
mean little bit different,
but you know,
I understand your pain point being.
If somebody comes in and starts criticizing you right when you're doing okay,
when you're doing a good job,
know you're doing a good job.
Yeah.
Nice.
I think you're doing a good job.
Thanks.
There's something that get on you about that base.
Occasionally.
That's your head that's really on you.
You know you're passing your base book.
Extreme ownership on my part.
So that's the thing.
If that's the decision you've gotta make,
and guess what?
It's not black and white.
You don't go into some units.
It's not like you're going to get a choice between a unit that's doing horrible
and a unit that's doing great.
You're going to get everything in between and therefore you have to modulate
your leadership to reflect.
If it's a,
if it's a group that might have a tendency of being a little bit jacked up and
they're getting close,
guess what?
You got to got to be maybe not sweeping changes,
but you might need to make a little statement,
right?
If it's a group that's performing awesome,
fantastic top,
top,
team,
whatever,
you might need to come and say,
hey guys,
I see that you're doing great.
I'm here to just keep you guys doing what you're doing.
Let me know what you need to support.
Boom.
And it could be anywhere in between that,
that spectrum.
That's why leadership is challenging,
cause you've gotta be old.
You got to have nuance.
You gotta be able to modulate.
Yeah.
You got to figure out where that is and you've got to test it out to.
Once you give that sweeping order,
you've got to see what kind of reaction you
got it.
You know,
you got to see two people just instantly rebel.
Okay,
then let's talk this.
Let's get some feedback.
What's going on?
Clearly we have a disrespect scenario going on.
When did you get the bottom of this?
Let me get some key leaders in here.
Let me talk to them,
get some feedback,
which you should do that before you make any sweeping changes anyway.
You've got to at least talk to the key leadership,
get them in the game,
get them on board.
Yeah,
that's why leadership is awesome.
That's why I beat,
that's why this stuff is so fun because it's challenging.
It's different every single time yet feels like,
um,
kind of like what we were talking about earlier where if you start to understand
the formula,
all the different details that come out and you can kind of apply the formula in
one way and even then still dynamic,
but,
but you can,
you can just get a better grasp.
It's just like Jujitsu because if you understand the concept,
yeah,
that's,
you have to be able to move your hips.
There's a bunch of different ways you can get your hips moving.
If you understand the concept that you need to do,
we'll mobilize the hips to pass the guard.
If you understand that concept,
there's all kinds of different ways you can do.
If you understand the concept of totally jacked up team is going to need a
sweeping change to get their attention and get them to understand that things
are gonna change and what they were doing was unacceptable.
If you understand that concept that that's what it's gonna take,
you can apply it all the way through those gradiations all the way down to,
hey,
this team is doing great and I don't need to change much.
I just need to give him the support that they need.
Conceptual instruction,
very important.
Solid.